What I'd like to obviously focus
on for, for this class is, um,
some of the green chemistry approaches.
Not going to take a deep dive,
but just give you a flavor of some of
the approaches that are, that are used.
Uh,
there's a whole science that has emerged
over the past at least 20 years, uh,
inherently safer processes.
Uh,
a person out of the UK named
Trevor collects is considered the,
the founder of this,
uh,
this area inherently safer
chemical processes. Um,
and it's looking at exactly
what we've been talking about,
how instead of reacting
and preventing exposure,
um,
do you understand the inherent nature
of the materials that are being used so
that they are intrinsically either
incapable or dramatically less capable of
causing an adverse consequences?
MMM.
So I give one example.
Our friend, phosgene,
we all know as acutely,
acutely lethal,
but yet still used and
very, very wide, uh, uh,
large scale, uh, applications. So a
methyl ISO cyanide. So the way
that you make methyl isocyanate,
uh,
on a large scale has always traditionally
been done using phosgene large
quantities of phosgene to,
to make this. And so, uh,
phosgene being the COC seal two
shown here to make not the lie.
So signing dupont came up
with an alternative, um,
uh,
after,
by a good friend named Leo man's arm out
of two plant after the Bhopal incident
that, uh, that we're not
gonna use postiion anymore.
We came up with a catalyst,
we're going to be able to use
carbon monoxide, um, which,
while deadly is not looks good
by comparison to fires team,
uh,
and so you'll start off with the,
with the methylamine use
carbon monoxide and a catalyst,
and you'd get through methyl lysozyme
completely eliminating phosgene from the
equation.
Sulfuric acid
is used in giant quantities,
has always historically been used
in giant quantities to make nylon.
So when you think of the volumes of nine
line that a produced and that it has in
two different steps,
come up with stoke geometric quantities
of sulfuric acid that's necessary.
And you start thinking about
those quantities and you
start thinking about the
accident potential for those
quantities of self uric acid was, um,
the alternative of getting rid of
it actually. And one step using, uh,
uh, uh, basically they're
solid acid catalyst.
So instead of sulfuric acid,
that catalytic solid acid catalyst,
this one's a titanium silver silicate.
The other one is a zeolite.
So now you don't have,
um,
the same kind of liquid. You don't
have the same kind of vapor, uh, that,
uh,
and all of the cascading consequences of,
of sulfuric acid.
This is a solid acid catalyst,
easier, handled, easier, contained,
dramatically less accident potential
from using solid acid catalysts like, uh,
like zeolites. Uh, so this
is a big, a big step forward.
Uh, the synthesis of Sinai. Uh,
the traditional way that you
produce cyanide is, uh, uh,
is using a process where you're going
to be combining methane and ammonia.
Um, but at the same time, because
the first step is so into thermic,
you need to put in so much energy
that you are actually combusting, um,
uh, an an air combustion of the
methane, uh, with, with oxygen,
uh, in order to drive that
first step of the reaction,
um,
which now we have ways
of doing a catalytically,
uh, with an external energy, a
sauce instead. And so it's a much,
much cleaner reaction.
Yeah.
Still producing cyanide.
Uh,
and so some of the other green chemistry,
nothings are,
uh, uh, just doing a, uh,
a process using Puma mud and he'd,
or using sodium cyanide and,
uh,
and uh,
and sulfuric acid.
Why would you care about whether or not
it's sodium cyanide or hydrogen cyanide
from an accident potential standpoint?
What formed is hydrogen cyanide come in?
What phase? What's that? Gas. Gas.
What is sodium cyanide
salt.
So from an accident potential,
why do you care
the gas in the gas in a solid pretty
much equal when it comes to accident
potential now? No, it's not. Uh, so,
uh, gas has a much, much
harder to, to handle.